bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission que vous pouvez savourer sur
une terrasse ou à l'intérieur et jusqu'à
23 heures
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler des sociétés du cac 40 et du
versement des dividendes bonjour amira
bonjour olivier bonjour à tous bienvenue
de ces cas sont dits que la crise
sanitaire a appauvri les plus pauvres et
enrichit les plus riches un récent
rapport de l'observatoire des
multinationales dans ce sens en tout cas
dans ce rapport on apprend que toutes
les entreprises du cac 40 ont perçu des
aides publiques et qu'une très grande
majorité a et va verser des dividendes à
ses actionnaires et on parle là de san
quentin milliards d'euros tout de même
mais comment est-ce possible notamment
car l'état n'a pas conditionner ses
aides une fois aperçu les grands on
pouvait manifestement faire ce qu'ils
voulaient alors ont-ils profité du
système le système les at il un peu
aidés on va essayer de répondre à cette
question avec notre invité de se re avec
mon deuxième partie stéphane petit box
et des enseignants en finance et en
économie explications avec le tiroir
cash d'antoine basse
[Musique]
c'est un rapport assez édifiant qu'à
publier l'observatoire des
multinationales alors que nous sommes en
pleine crise qu vide et que la politique
du quoi qu'il en coûte de l'état n'est
pas encore terminée 24 pages qu'on ne va
pas pouvoir vous détailler en une minute
trente
du coup on va juste vous sortir quelques
chiffres assez pertinents alors que 100
% des entreprises du cac 40 total sanofi
lvmh et autres auraient touché des aides
de l'état que ce soit sous forme
d'exonérations de charges chômage
partiel ou à travers les fameux pge
elles vont reverser cette année 51
milliards d'euros de dividendes à leurs
actionnaires
près de 20 % de plus par rapport à
l'année dernière
la france étant le pays d'europe ayant
le plus cdc entreprises en 2020 avec
d'ailleurs assez peu de condition ça
fait forcément tâche
d'ailleurs autre chiffre 80% des
entreprises ayant versé de l'argent à
leurs actionnaires cette année ou
l'année dernière où une recours au
chômage partiel
parallèlement à ça le cac40 aurait
également licencié près de soixante deux
mille cinq cents personnes dans le monde
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
dont trente mille en france
mais alors qui sont ces fameux
actionnaires qui touchent des dividendes
ils sont nombreux mais en top position
de ceux ayant reçu le plus avec 1,7
milliard d'euros
on trouve par exemple le fonds
d'investissement blackrock ayant investi
dans la quasi totalité des grandes
entreprises tricolores en deuxième
position
vinet quoi basse élite à un peu plus de
1,6 milliard ou comprend donc un peu
mieux pourquoi à freiner les dividendes
des grandes entreprises françaises
n'étaient pas forcément une priorité
olivier a manifestement la crise n'a pas
été vécue de la même manière par tout le
monde non mais en fait c'est là qu'on
voit les limites de la gestion de l'état
ou l'incompétence de l'état c'est que on
verse des aides à des gens qui n'en ont
pas besoin
il aurait été quand même plus malin de
cibler les sociétés qui avaient vraiment
besoin
dead qui avait vraiment besoin de
recourir au chômage partiel qui avait
besoin de deux des prêts garanties
d'état ex terra plutôt que de le de lui
le maître unanimement sur toutes les
sociétés du cac 40
cette est idiot on en paye les
conséquences comme d'habitude mais c'est
pas la première fois que l'état fait des
choses idiotes
merci olivier tout de suite la deuxième
partie de cette émission est avec nous
notre invité stéphane petit bond et les
enseignants en finance économie stéphane
petit blond bienvenu merci d'être avec
nous si j'étais france alors on va
commencer par quelques chiffres 1 100 %
du cac 40 bénéficie dette publique et
ces mêmes entreprises ont réussi à
verser 51 milliards d'euros à leurs
actionnaires soit l'équivalent de cent
quarante pour cent de leurs profits en
2020 stéphane petit bon c'est plutôt
édition c'est édifiant mais chez c'est
pas illégal voilà le problème
on a un modèle il pas que français elle
est en tout cas en france
il est partie prenante on nous si vous
commencez à verser des subventions à
certains secteurs économiques du point
de vue sectoriel et pas un autre
il ya alors
c'est l'absurdité de notre ce système
légal il ya ce qu'on appelle la rupture
d'équité d'égalité et donc il est clair
qu'en termes de subventions qui suit le
droit il est clair qu'ils ne pouvaient
pas s'en défendent bien entendu cette
absurdité
après en terme de chiffres mais il ne
pouvait pas et subventionner des petites
entreprises sans malheureusement aussi
subventionner les grands
alors ça c'est un cetain un paradoxe
mais c'est le paradoxe du droit
financier en france il ya un autre
problème qui a été soulevée c'est aussi
la peur qu'avec le gouvernement alors
cette peur elle vient de d'une chose qui
est quand même qui va devenir et qui
commence à devenir préoccupant c'est que
malgré la présence de grands groupes
dont des 40 grosses sociétés qui
marchent en consolidation d'ailleurs en
filiales et c'est parce qu'il ya toute
une mécanique financière derrière qui
leur permettent de localiser de baisser
leur imposition différée dans des pays
pas très très loin d'ailleurs de la
france ils le font tous c'est le
phénomène de la mondialisation qui
existe depuis les années 90 qui se fait
leur s est accélérée d'ailleurs dans les
années 2000 donc ces sociétés sont alors
physiquement localisée encore sur la
france pour leur maison mère mais la
majorité de leurs filiales se retrouvant
à l'étranger il faut 70 à 75% morsi
d'affaires hors de france
donc tous les tous les problèmes des ddd
prix de transfert etc qui leur permet
tout simplement de faire de
l'optimisation fiscale
mais si je me mets du côté de l'étang et
d'un rapport qui est sorti ya pas très
longtemps de france stratégie sur la
politique industrielle en france qui a
été publié en novembre 2020
il est clair
il ya quelque chose de beaucoup plus
préoccupant que cela c'est la phase de
désindustrialisation très rapide que la
france est en train de vivre et donc
forcément les grands groupes le savent
et ils en profitent c'est pas non plus
bonne situation
c'est à dire que ces grandes sociétés
profitent largement du fait qu' on a
besoin d'entreprises de relocaliser des
entreprises
si ce n'est d'en créer d'autres sur
notre territoire pour ensuite utiliser
ce chantage un tout petit peu
stratégiques et financiers pour obtenir
tout ce qu'ils veulent en termes de
subvention de chômage partiel si ce
n'est de pge voilà donc ça c'est une
analyse qui ressort si vous voulez de la
politique macroéconomique depuis depuis
un an et depuis une dizaine d'années
mais depuis un an notamment
bon il est clair qu'on verra si les
prêts garantis par l'état seront
remboursés à l'état à terme alors
débloqué des aides publiques massives 1
pour adèle secteur privé face à la crise
sanitaire très bien mme olivier pourquoi
l'état n'a pas assujettis c'est za de
véritables conditions conditions
fiscales environnementales conditions
par rapport au versement des dividendes
notamment parce que
le
le coc vide je voulais dit que vite
c'est un prétexte c'est ça ça va
permettre à beaucoup d'entreprises comme
par exemple les banques de faire le
ménage chez eux c'est-à-dire de virer
des dizaines et des dizaines d'employés
des centaines d'employés
parce que ils savent qu'ils ont besoin
mais ça ça date d'avant le coc vide ils
ont besoin de fermer des agences
bancaires ils ont besoin d'hectares et
il pouvait difficilement le faire avant
et là tout d'un coup il ya ce créneau du
coc vie qui leur permet de mettre sur le
dos du coc vident leur licenciement et
ils le font et d'un autre côté on leur
impose rien alors pourquoi est ce qu'on
leur a imposé moi j'ai pas la réponse
simplement vous avez un état qui a dit
ok j'arrose comme d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'états n'ya pas il n'y a pas que la
france qui a fait ça ok j'arrose et les
entreprises elles en ont bénéficié
quelle que soit l'heure quelles que
soient leurs leurs conditions à ce
moment là et pourquoi est ce que mon
cher ami bruno le maire n'a pas mis 2
deux conditions à ces aides je ne peux
pas vous le dire mais tout ce que je
sais c'est qu'il en a pas mis et que ça
arrange quand même beaucoup
d'entreprises
le fait est qu'on aurait très bien pu
mettre des conditions mais qu'on savait
que de toute façon c'était pas tenable
vous pouvez pas vous pouvez pas prêter
de l'argent à une boîte en faillite
comme air france et lui dire mais si je
te prête de l'argent
tu ne peux pas licencier du personnel ça
ne ça ne tient pas debout donc
et de toute façon malheureusement ça
n'aura servi à rien parce que vous
verrez que on va continuer à aider air
france qui sera en faillite permanente
donc voila et le on va on ne peut pas
mettre dans certains cas des conditions
donc on n'en met pas du tout et puis
comme ça les choses vont bien et que y
ait des gens qui en profitent n'est pas
étonnant en soi
on sait que c'est pas des enfants de
choeur les patrons du cac40 donc alors
après moi ça me choque pas du tout qui
versent des dividendes en 2000 en 2021
pour l'année 2020 mais ça me choque un
peu quand quand j'apprends qu'on l'ait
qu'ils ont profité des aides et qu'ils
versent des dividendes
sinon il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de
problème si vous si vous n'avez pas eu
d' aide et que votre activité a bien
marché il ya aucune raison ne pas verser
des dividendes
olivier on va continuer d'en parler mais
tout de suite c'est la pause
est toujours là dedans c'est casse avec
notre invité stéphane petit bon
enseignant en finance et en économie on
parlait des aides publiques un perçue
par les entreprises du cac40 pas de
conditions donc pour ces lettres
stéphane petibon pas de conditions non
plus par rapport à la préservation de
l'emploi ainsi 80% des groupes du cac 40
ayant eu recours au chômage partiel ont
versé un dividende en 2020 et ou en 2021
est-ce que c'est là vous étonne non ça
m'étonne pas il ya il y avait surtout en
france et ailleurs est une sorte de
paradoxe depuis à peu près une trentaine
d'années qui s'y développer les sociétés
du cac 40 sont soumis et j'aurais
peut-être puis ça c'est une chose qui
est qui et qui a été vérifié par un
rapport de 2010 et un taux de
prélèvements obligatoires qui se situe
aux alentours de 60 de taux marginal
d'imposition avoir abattement et
déductions fiscales et de l'autre côté
on a des subventions des pg e des du
chômage partiel reversés à tour larigot
à toutes ces sociétés là moi j'ai
l'impression que on a un état qui n'est
plus stratège on a un état qui anticipe
très mal on a un état qui essaye de se
substituer très souvent à des
investissements dont ils sont pas
capables d'ailleurs de comprendre la
capacité stratégique et comme ils savent
et sage c'est une chose qui est
maintenant intacte et on est à 200 il ya
220 milliards de dettes de plus donc on
sera allé à 118 % d'être sûr pipe arrêt
de compte actuellement en projection
pendant au bout de deux ans on sera à
là on plaisante plus à 130% et donc a
priori
ce dont ils ont peur et notamment bercy
l'inspection des finances était terrassé
que ces sociétés quittent la france
définitivement donc quand un grand
patron d'un grand patron je pense que
son père était plus grands patrons qu
lui un arnould l'ayguade lagardère mais
avec toutes les relations qui la prend
rendez vous à l'inspection des finances
en bas on lui accorde quand même un
certain nombre de facilités de recevoir
des subventions etc
mais ça cette cooptation qui a entre les
politiques et le monde des affaires a
toujours fait sienne dans ce pays depuis
depuis un siècle et demi voilà ce qui
est ce qui est dommage c'est que les
conséquences de ce genre de comportement
c'est un regard de la société civile
contre les entreprises
alors qu'on a besoin d'entreprises donc
c'était l'image qui négative
ça c'est clair et ensuite aussi contre
les politiques
1 parce que faire déficit pour faire de
la relance en découpant de la dette
depuis à peu près une trentaine d'années
sans avoir changé en quoi que ce soit
modifié en quoi que ce soit leur modèle
politique alors le modèle économique
là on va on va encore payer l'addition
donc on est toujours dans une sorte de
paradoxe
on n'est pas tout à fait qu'aider gien
mais on n'est pas non plus tout à fait
libérale
on passe d'un modèle à un autre sans
avoir une ligne de réformes qui
devraient passer pendant au moins comme
en allemagne une dizaine d'années pour
arriver à changer un modèle qui
fonctionne plus donc on est toujours
entre deux eaux maintenant la conclusion
de cet aspect là c'est bien entendu le
supra nationale qui va payer tout ça la
france
moi en tout cas c'est l'analyse que j'ai
et que nous avons avec un certain nombre
de mes confrères
la france n'a pas totalement ou
partiellement d un disque réalisé à 8 ou
9% n'a plus les moyens d'assumer une
dette de 130
40% ça je suis clair là dessus et là on
va vers de gros problèmes donc on va
passer aux supranationale
on verra si ça fonctionne 1 c'est à dire
les fameuses 'eurobonds' 1 qui vont
assurer des dettes supplémentaires ont
en tout cas celles qui sont déjà
existantes
mais bien entendu nous sommes pas en
modèle fédéral et comme on a vu à la
sortie de la crise des subprimes avec
simplement 300 milliards de dettes ce
qui est maintenant elle est rien pour
nous - de la grèce a créé une crise
européenne majeure je crains qu'à la
sortie du colis les discussions à
bruxelles soit particulièrement musclé
on attend l'élection du prochain
chancelier de l'allemagne mais on verra
comment ça va se passer parce que là
j'ai été quand même très étonné que
l'allemagne accepte acceptent d'aller
sur les euro montrent alors moi j'ai eu
ça peut remarque pour conclure de ça
c'est c'est bien entendu les les
allemands sont en train de sauver leurs
clients je vois pas accepter une chose
pareille stéphane petit bond pour
revenir sur l'un de vos propos ans la
france est le pays de l'union européenne
qui serait le plus désindustrialisé
depuis les années à ce sinistre
olivier est ce que ce déclin peut
expliquer en partie pourquoi la france
tient tant à ses entreprises ben non si
elle y tenait
elle aurait fait en sorte que l part pas
donc non ccc simplement que
aujourd'hui les les il fallait en tout
cas dans l'esprit de nos de nos
dirigeants il fallait tout faire pour
essayer de créer une illusion de reprise
et et de de contrôle de la situation
mais je vous dis la situation elle leur
a échappé pas en mars 2020 laura
échappés dès 2008 et dès 2008 on a on a
accumulé les erreurs
on a on n'a rien réglé on a mis la
poussière sous le tapis et la première
crise qui passe
il y avait déjà la crise grecque en 2011
la crise de l'euro en 2011 et puis une
nouvelle crise mais qui qui au final ne
fait qu'accélérer les choses qui ne fait
que amplifier les choses mais qui n'est
pas le la cause de nos maux et donc
on a des zus industrialisés depuis
longtemps sans rien faire sans rien
changer et donc vous ne pourrez pas
avoir gelé dit plusieurs fois ici
si vous ne changez pas le le modèle
économique français
eh bien vous n'aurez pas de retour des
entreprises pourquoi pensez-vous
une entreprise qui part elle part parce
qu' un certain nombre de données ne lui
vont pas dans le six dans l'écosystème
qui dans lequel elle et elle part à
l'extérieur
si vous ne changez pas l'écosystème elle
a aucune raison de revenir
et donc c'est pas parce que vous le
dites en disant on va ré industrialiser
mais que vous ne faites rien eh bien
vous aurez un résultat nul
comme d'habitude alors très rapidement
pour conclure cette émission va parler
du patron de lvmh bernard arnault
d'ailleurs qui a pour la première fois
depuis près de six ans a figuré en tête
du classement forbes
c'était un c'est éphémère et je vais le
site et il l'a dit et les crises nous
rende plus fort une citation donc de
bernard arnault s'était fin avril quand
elle commentait les bons résultats
financiers du numéro un mondial du luxe
les crises nous rend plus fort ses fans
petits bouts est-ce que c'est indécent
de cette période non c'est pas deschamps
on a affaire à quelqu'un qui est
excessivement brillant quand même pas
l'oublier c'est une phrase de schumpeter
qui s'appelle la destruction créatrice
il est clair que les sociétés qui ont
tenu le coup durant le coc bid auront
une capacité de se développer beaucoup
plus rapidement derrière ça s'est
toujours vu un on s'est aperçu qu'il
était nu que lorsque la marée s'y
retirer à partir du moment où la marée
se retire on voit les plus forts bon par
contre
je rejoins ce que disait olivier
delamarche tout à l'heure on voit pas
malheureusement on voit pas suffisamment
les plus faibles c'est à dire ceux qui
n'auraient jamais dû reprendre une
activité à la sortie du collège
ça c'est la position libérale celle qui
n'est pas défendu d'ailleurs par la
france mais défendue par d'autres pays
européens subventionner des sociétés
continuer à subventionner des sociétés
ont des rentabilités trop faible et qui
vous font des dettes à tire larigot
ce n'est plus possible alors on va voir
je suis sceptique de savoir si on va
changer le modèle
nous on a plutôt tendance à
subventionner des entreprises qui sont
plus rentables et les sept principes
qu'on a qui nous augmente ne tête d'une
façon considérable d'une addition
stephen petibon êtes enseignant en
finance en économie merci pour votre
éclairage repris et olivier on se
retrouve tout de suite pour la troisième
et dernière partie de cette émission
la troisième et dernière partie de cette
émission avec les questions qu'a soulevé
depuis le début de la crise d'état vient
au secours des entreprises et de
l'économie créant inéluctablement une
dette
l'hypothèse d'une taxe pour rembourser
la dette liée à la cobi 19 étaient de
plus en plus forte jusqu'à cette
proposition de notre ami olivier
monsieur le maire annuler la dette mais
contrairement à la dette déjà connu
permettant de financer les services
publics cette nouvelle dette et
exclusivement orientés sur les secteurs
privés on en revient donc à la question
olivier pourquoi ne pourrait-on pas
également annulé la dette publique lui
mais annulons toutes les dettes
un jeu j'appelle tout le monde à aller
s'acheter un appartement une maison
et puis vous irez voir votre banquier en
lui disant et si finalement on annuler
toutes les dettes bas parce que c'est
quand même un principe très sympa pour
un nouveau modèle extraordinaire on fait
on fait deux mille sept cents ou de 1800
milliards de dettes et puis on les
efface on va appeler
bruno le maire le type ex qui permet
d'effacer les bandes enfin ccef un
moment où il faut réfléchir quand même
autre chose
effacez la dette vous avez au final
quelqu'un qui paye toujours
il n'y a pas de ce qu'on dise qu'on dit
en bourse n'a pas de free lunch
ça n'existe pas donc à un moment il ya
quelqu'un qui paye
dans cette histoire même si vous annulez
la bête vous avez quelqu'un qui paye
donc quand on fait de la dette comme on
en a fait dans tous les états il n'y a
pas que la france
loin de là même aux états unis il ya eu
une création de dettes
incroyable depuis depuis les deux
dernières années donc vous aurez
quelqu'un qui au final paiera d'une
manière ou d'une autre
alors après vous pouvez appelez ça comme
vous voulez soit une hausse des impôts
ce qui est tout à fait probable couplé
avec si vous voulez une annulation de
dette on sait pas très bien comme
d'ailleurs parce qu'ils en parlent
beaucoup mais ils vous disent pas
techniquement comment ça va se passer
vous annulez une date c'est un contrat
entre une entreprise privée et une autre
entreprise privée entre une banque et
une entreprise privée qui acquit à qui
s'est endettée est ce que vous faites
vous annulé la dette le banquier qu'est
ce qu'il va faire il va se retrouver en
perte
donc au final vous avez toujours
quelqu'un qui paie merci olivier c'est
la fin de cette émission consacrée aux
entreprises du cac 40 et aux aides
publiques qu'elles ont reçues merci à
vous pour votre fidélité
olivier vous laisse avec le mot de la
fin bien je viens à l'instant de vous
dire no free lunch mais en fait pour le
cac 40
c'est manger sans payer l'addition